welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and call me crazy y'all but i do not
think that we have seen the last of
black widow in the mcu i mean yes i am
aware that scarlett did take a tumble on
vormir for the good of the ashy half of
the universe and we did see her body you
know laying down in a pool of blood but
if you think a fall from several hundred
feet in the air is gonna kill natasha
real one romanov think again nerds think
again i truly believe that kevin feige
and marvel studios have been secretly
laying down sneaky clues behind in their
recent mcu projects like what if loki
sheng chi black widow and even possibly
the upcoming eternals film that could
likely lead to natasha romanov's return
to the live-action portion of the mcu
either as a multiverse variant or
through the full restoration of our
natasha romanoff proper like some type
of hot russian jesus or something so
let's get to speculating my beautiful
speculation nation nerd babies let's
start off with marvel studios newest
potential avenue towards more gnat
action scientifically known as naktion
is of course through marvel's first
season of what if and nope not the one
who was murdered by you know falling
down to michael douglas she's dead the
gnat from the season finale you know the
one that saved the universe from a
maniac with infinity stones as natashas
are prone to do and then at the end of
the finale we see uatu the watcher in a
stunning and outstanding move violate
his oath of non-interference by gifting
the avengerless universe a significantly
less dead black widow for the low low
price of 399. what a great deal and you
know nick fury was not about to look a
big bald black bargain horse in the
multiverse mouth no sir but here's the
thing the tva is still very much a thing
and after loki did the pokey to the man
in the purple cloaky the tva now has
multiple variants of itself to deal with
the madness that sylvie unleashed upon
the multiverse you see this is why
everyone should just leave black owned
businesses alone just let black people
run black owned businesses kidding
sylvie definitely did the right thing
because that man was nuts this means
that it is highly likely that the tva
will eventually have to deal with this
natasha not belonging in the reality
where you know the hulk popped like
squidward in the krabby patty vault
which could mean that ultra lord willing
we could see this natasha romanov
variant pop up in loki season 2 possibly
as a live-action arrested criminal on
death row wouldn't that be great and
it'd be an amazing way to have a
live-action haley atwell captain carter
cameo and loki as a means of breaking
her friend out of prison which could
eventually potentially lead to natasha's
eventual reintroduction into the main
live-action mcu universe proper because
homies don't let homies get kidnapped by
religious cults they just don't if your
homie lets you get kidnapped by a
religious cult that's not a real one
that's not a real friend there are a lot
of parts of life that can't be
customized to fit to you but thanks to
helix a mattress is not one of those
helix sleep makes premium mattresses and
bedding customized to fit your needs and
shipped right to your door helix has a
sleep quiz that matches your unique body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you and here at new
rockstars eric took the quiz and got
matched with the dusk lux helix mattress
because he wanted a medium firm mattress
with lumbar support that sleeps cool and
boy is his lumbar supported i see him
every day and i'm like oh my god look at
that lumbar oh my goodness and he's had
his helix mattress for over a year and
loves it and it totally delivers on all
their great features and if you sleep
with a partner both of you can take the
quiz and find the mattress that meets
both of your needs and helix delivers
your mattress right to your door for
free it comes rolled up in a
surprisingly small box and is super easy
to set it up yourself and helix has a
100 night sleep trial so you get more
than three months to make sure that you
love it and if you don't they'll pick it
up for you and you'll get a full refund
i love my helix eric loves his helix and
i think you will love your helix too if
you're looking for a new bed check out
helix you can check out the link below
or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress that is helix sleep.com
rockstars okay seeing variants of our
favorite characters are cool and all but
it definitely isn't as cool as you know
a full resurrection of the characters
that we know and love am i right here's
the deal gang i don't think natasha
romanov is dead at all and i believe
that her solo film may hold a very
subtle hint that could point to just how
that we could see her fully resurrected
in the mcu in the future because i think
that there is more to that structure on
that top of that mountain on vormir than
meets the eye it's a really sketchy
structure i don't trust it okay so
remember that moment at the beginning of
black widow when young natasha could not
believe her eyes the 10 million
fireflies with her make-believe mama
molina the glow that you see
that comes from a chemical reaction
called bioluminescence and then how the
movie ended with fireflies dancing
around a tree yeah that was all
intentional and all symbolic
foreshadowing because i think that the
concept of bioluminescence is linked to
the concept of the soul in the mcu
specifically connected to our
bioelectrical potential and this is
something that is going to be covered in
the upcoming eternals film it's all
about the energies of our planet you
know the human electricity type energy
inside of all of our body molecules and
we see this example best illustrated in
this scene in thor the dark world where
jane foster is placed on an asgardian
soul forge which is basically a magic
x-ray of jane foster's
potential that is being sapped by that
pesky primordial pinot noir ass reality
stone goop and a piece of asgardian
technology that jane foster refers to as
a quantum field generator it's a soul
food does the soul forge transfer
molecular energy from one place to
another yes
one field generator yes guardians
literally refer to the molecular life
energy in living beings as the soul i
suspect that this is how the science of
astral projection works within the
doctor strange films as doctor strange
is able to defeat that astral [ __ ]
easily after his body was charged with
electrical energy from a defibrillator
[Music]
and of course this soul science of
bioelectrical potential was the main
focus of iron man 3 through of course
killian's extremist project that used
bioelectricity to reorient the soul to
enhance and better heal the body hmm i
wonder where else we've heard that
before no mr strange
i know how to reorient the spirit to
better heal the body now this all being
said i don't think black widow died on
vormir i believe that her soul left her
body before the body hit the ground
during that soul stone exchange you know
kind of like when woos was in chiang chi
and then was sent through that giant
wormhole in the sky that nobody likes to
talk about for some reason there was
literally a giant ass wormhole just
chilling in the sky and you can
literally see two beams of light shoot
into that wormhole after natasha
sacrifice and one of those beams i
believe is natasha's soul and the other
being could be the soul of the red skull
because i don't think that this dude has
much of a body anymore especially after
he [ __ ] up in captain america one i
think his body burned away then that's
why he's this wraith form now he's just
a soul to me this structure on vormir is
sort of like a soul tuning fork and i am
of the mind that natasha's soul was
emailed from the center of that mcu
universe to the center of another mcu
universe remember that imagery of the
zoom in and zoom out of those two
universes at the beginning of the loki
finale with all the voiceovers and
whatnot i believe that natasha's
bioelectrical soul went from the center
of one of those universes to the center
of that other universe and that natasha
romanov could have been reborn possibly
in one of the reactivation chambers of
the eternals because in the comics
whenever the physical form of an eternal
died their essences were preserved in
their physical forms reborn in eternal
activation chambers so if natasha's
father ivan happened to be i don't know
uh ivan druid of the eternals then yeah
her uh bioelectricity would be a pretty
damn good candidate for resurrection in
one of these activation chambers
possibly in a different form because
that's what happens sometimes i mean i'm
pretty sure sprite went from being a boy
to a girl but those are just some of the
avenues that i think the mcu could be
taking to bring nat back to our loving
embrace which one of those two theories
do you think is the most likely let us
know below my nerd babies but yeah thank
you guys so much for watching this video
please do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to find all of our
cool shirts also please do not forget to
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] and most importantly please do not
forget to follow new rockstars on
twitter and also just wherever we are
especially on youtube and don't forget
to hit that notification bell so you can
get notifications whenever we upload a
new video i love you guys so much truly
stay safe and i'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you